good-morning reject nation I'm Greg Alba
now I'm John Humphrey we are going to
watch the official trailer for a Toy
Story 4 I hope this is a real trailer
because we've got a lot of like things
random bits with key and Peele before we
go into that I would of course like to
say a special thank you to everyone who
has followed us on our patreon page -
and we do weekly Q&A and we also do TV
show reactions stream alongs for several
shows that includes one punch man Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood my hero
academia I did all of attack on Titan
Gotham the haunting of Hill House and
supernatural and we also do reaction
highlights with footage included for
several shows that includes one punch
man my hero academia supernatural and
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood and he
also does plenty of music video coverage
go to our patreon page see if you want
to become a patron today to plug in the
patreon it let's do it
[Music]
is the most important way to body right
now we all have to make sure nothing
happens to it we have a situation
[Music]
no--you're
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
awesome right that's right around the
corner here yeah comes out June 21st huh
Woody's lost again maybe he doesn't want
to come back I love Tony Hale not
because doing the voices if there's
anyone who could do charming and warm
and creepy and so for him to do the
voices sport he's very nice for Kevin I
keep calling sporky I wonder why I mean
they make a joke about it and everything
but the this trailer this has
surprisingly a lack of buzz lightyear in
here this is sort of be a calm it feels
more on 2 min Toy Story 2 than the other
ones mm-hmm and this is kind of
repeating some things that the Toy Story
franchise has done already Woody's lost
what keep him wherever he is and away
from his person or whatever yeah what it
seems like a big part of the new
relationship will come with the thing of
for key right here yeah like some of the
newer dynamics and I like the sort of
reinvention of Bo Peep here yes it's
been cuz she's not really into Story 3
and they said that that's gonna be a big
part of it and it certainly seems like
she is gonna be one of the main sort of
catalysts of this story well they were
separated another reunited and I know
that in you know the Toy Story the
franchise woody and Bo Peep they're in
love with each other but you know you've
never really a integral part of the
stories yeah it was just sort of a funny
little side thing that would happen and
then this one actually gonna get a
romantic tail between the two which I'm
actually looking forward to and I like
the reinvention of a because I feel like
if this was the Bo Peep that it was
before it might be a little annoying and
I'm okay with this new version of Bo
Peep and I find this a lot more
appealing of a of a story well time has
passed you know and you know now that
the toys have been handed off to Bonnie
I'm assuming that in some fashion we're
gonna have to learn a little
more about Bonnie that little bond what
I live in a trailer park what the hell's
going on yeah they're just on a road
trip here which looks nice and the
carnival experience and you notice woody
caught between oh should I go back with
my toys or B with Bo Peep in this
carnival world should I choose my work
or my love
he's gonna go with Bonnie and the end he
promote I mean it'd be a different
ending if he didn't go with Bonnie
though well I mean I saw an interview
with with you know I'm blanking his name
right now for series Tim Allen it's not
an interview it's him out it he said the
end of this movie he read the script if
he couldn't get through it without like
weeping it's so emotional and Hanks said
that the the way this movie ends up is
like a moment in history so apparently
they're gearing up for some kind of huge
emotional climax with this movie which
you know that makes me wonder if maybe
they'll go on a direction that we're not
exactly expecting for them to go in I
hope so because this plot itself seems
like a retread of a lot of things they
seem to be keeping the heart of how
emotional Toy Story 3 was yeah and
they're letting that heart still linger
on here based off the tone of this
trailer because it's less wacky and
there's like some wacky stuff in here
but it definitely has an emotional depth
that the last one gave us and I you know
just bit but based off like plot points
woody lost woody torn between two things
buzz and the toys and we got to go find
what do you like a lot of this is very
repetitive evil toys keep me here and
then which I don't mind a buddy I mean
if you're taught that thing about the
ending actually what you just told me it
got me more excited than anything in the
actual trailer got me excited for it
because I'm like what's the different
thing they're gonna have here what are
these goosebumps different roller coast
like dolls called again that's all they
are
yeah there's static goosebumps though
right yeah and I don't know I mean I
always like those elements of these
movies they bring in like different toys
they reference
other things that are like actually from
you know kind of the history of I like
this sort of antique mall that they're
in and even though they've liked Blade
Runner II arcade the city and stuff like
that and the promise of the carnival
like I feel like this could expand the
world pretty cool man one of the source
have to die you know because at the end
of the day there and the toy sort of
franchise is about toys that are alive
that are working on a survival oh yeah
cap and buzzes Iron Man and they're both
gonna go out in this one they're gonna
pass on the mantle Gianna Reeves play I
think I was wondering if he's that
mustachioed guy who popped up for like a
hot second and it's just his face and he
never speaks in this trailer but he has
like his own a featured shot I was
thinking they were thinking maybe that's
him I want to play the John wick Toy
Story as he shoots all them and yeah
because yeah because somebody kills
slinky yeah he just can't have that
imagine there there gonna be a lot of
branded toys in the toy universe well I
mean this looks like it looks good looks
delightful experience mm-hmm and before
we wrap this video up I think now is the
perfect time to shout out this specific
patron his name on patreon is Melvin
Ickx I don't know what that means that's
it for your shadow that his whole name
is tamir Streeter which is a badass name
this guy comes all the way from the
island Oahu which is in Hawaii and over
there he said he's been watching us
since his freshman year of high school
that's around the time when the first
Toy Story movie came out I'm so happy
that this guy is able to go to college
pursue his dream he right now is working
on a comic book series he does character
designs and since this is an animated
movie I figured this is the perfect
video to shut you out on buddy dude I
just followed you on Instagram I don't
know why you're not following me you're
one of our highest pledges right now on
patreon yet I don't see a follow on my
Instagram so can i really be grateful
for your pledge takes these things very
very personally I mean our friendship
wasn't even solidified until I followed
in my Instagram and Instagram didn't
need to be exist for like the first
several years of our friendship so you
can tell a seriousness guys
yeah yeah you got accept the pledge
thanks man good look on your comic book
series my dude well now you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us on
patreon with see guys ooh